Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do: Administer spankings to Dr. Rights.
If Dr. Rights is found to be in violation
of any Foundation rules or regulations, there
are existing disciplinary actions in place
that should be abided by.
Dr. Bright is to be reminded that corporal
punishment is not considered an acceptable
method of discipline in a professional environment,
or anywhere else.
It doesn't matter if "His parents spanked
him and he turned out fine," he did not turn
out fine, and he is not Dr. Rights' parent.
The HR department is tired of dealing with
this, and if it is not handled, Laura from
that department has said, quote, "I'll throw
him out my office window, and I'm not joking."
She's not joking.
Cut it out.